[Música]
Sudán está inverso en lo que podría ser
su tercera guerra civil desde la
independencia esto sería la tercera en
67 años de historia y ya sé lo que
pensaréis casi todos y a mí que me
importa su dan Pero eso Dónde está en el
mapa pues lo cierto Es que Sudán importa
mucho más de lo que crees
de entrada tiene un tamaño similar al de
México eso le convierte en el tercer
país más grande de África De hecho antes
de que se separase entre Sudán y Sudán
del sur y era el país más grande de todo
el continente pero no solo eso fijaos de
nuevo en el mapa si os dais cuenta
veréis que Sudán tiene salida al mar
rojo por donde pasa el 10% de todo el
comercio marítimo mundial además Sudán
tiene un montón de recursos naturales
petróleo Pues sí tienen petróleo A ver
no es que estén nadando en zumo de
dinosaurio pero tienen yacimientos y
sobre todo tienen oro y diréis cuánto
oro Pues el suficiente como para llamar
la atención de Rusia o para ser más
concretos del grupo wagners Los mismos
del intento del golpe de estado prigosin
tiene vínculos con una de las facciones
que luchan en la guerra de Sudán Y
diréis cómo le pagan Pues con derechos
para explotar las minas de oro pero
esperado un momento porque no solo
estamos hablando de Rusia También
tenemos otras dos potencias Arabia
Saudita y emiratos árabes Unidos Sí ya
lo sé estos dos países son aliados
tradicionalmente pero en este caso
apoyan a bandos diferentes
porque este conflicto es tan importante
[Música]
y por encima de todo tenemos el desastre
humanitario que todo esto supone ya
sabéis que los conflictos en África
tienden a recrudecerse una barbaridad Y
a convertirse en todo un baño de sangre
de hecho el secretario general de la ONU
Antonio Gutiérrez ya ha hecho saltar las
alarmas
en particular
ya lo veis aunque solo sea por puro
interés humanitario hay que enterarse
bien de lo que está pasando en Sudán
hablamos de un país tradicionalmente
dominado por los militares A mediados de
abril de este año estallan en los
combates para hacerse por el control de
Cartoon que es la capital se enfrentaban
las tropas leales al general que
precedía el país frente a la milicia
liderada por el que hasta entonces Será
su vicepresidente cuatro meses después
la lucha continúa por ahora ya llevamos
más de 5.000 víctimas mortales y más de
2 millones de desplazados y la capital
jartum está siendo devastada así que la
pregunta es por qué ha estallado un
conflicto tan brutal en Sudán qué
intereses tienen las potencias situadas
detrás de uno y otro bando Qué puede
pasar en los próximos meses hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
los diablos a caballo
principios del siglo XIX los gobernantes
del por entonces Egipto otomano
conquistaron lo que hoy se corresponde
con la mayor parte del territorio de
Sudán sin embargo en 1899 Sudán se
convirtió en un dominio del imperio
británico ahora bien en 1959 se
independizaron y muchos diréis pues qué
buena noticia Qué bien que los udaneses
puedan decidir Su futuro convirtiéndose
en una vibrante democracia verdad pues
va a ser que no
Sudán es el país de África que ha
sufrido más golpes de estado desde su
independencia se contabilizan 16 de los
cuales 6 han tenido éxito los militares
han acabado así con hasta tres intentos
de establecer una democracia en el país
el más reciente en 2021 Así mismo Sudán
ha vivido dos guerras civiles una de 17
años y otra de 22 el conflicto
desencadenado en abril amenaza con ser
la Tercera Guerra Civil sudanesa
habéis oído bien de los 67 años que
tiene la República de Sudán se han
tirado combatiendo durante más de 39 es
decir más de la mitad de su historia
diréis Por qué combatían pues fue la
lucha de Sudán del sur para crear un
estado independiente porque tienen una
población mayoritariamente cristiana
mientras que en el resto del país son
esencialmente musulmanes finalmente los
sudaneses consiguieron su independencia
en 2011 se llevaron el 25% del
territorio y el 75% de las reservas
petroleras Eso sí acuérdate para
compartir el zumo de dinosaurio ahora
bien estos recursos han servido de muy
poco al país más joven del mundo porque
Oh sorpresa en estos 12 años de
Independencia ya han tenido su propia
Guerra Civil de nada menos que 7 años
pero esperad un momento porque las dos
guerras civiles son solo una parte de la
tragedia sudanesa También tenemos que
contar con el conflicto de darfurt así
lo denominaba en el año 2006 el por
entonces secretario general de la ONU
coffee Ana denomina a darfur como la
peor crisis humanitaria del mundo y
diréis Pero qué pasó en darfur os hago
un resumen
en 1989 llegó al poder en Sudán el
general Omar albasir dominó el país
durante 30 años y estableció una
dictadura dominada desde cartoon por una
élite islamista sin embargo en las
regiones periféricas del país las cosas
serán diferentes en la región de darfur
convivían etnias negras africanas con
etnias árabes los negros se dedicaban a
la agricultura mientras que los árabes
se dedicaban al pastoreo y como ya os
podéis imaginar los ganaderos y los
labradores se peleaban por el territorio
tanto es así que en 2003 las etnias
africanas estallaron en una rebelión
estaban hartos del olvido al que estaban
sometidos por el poder central de jartum
y ahí es cuando el general Omar albasir
que por el nombre deduciréis que es
árabe mandó al ejército y además
recurrió a los yangyawid y diréis
quiénes son los yangyawid
[Música]
[Aplausos]
significa demonios a caballo y es el
nombre de la milicia que utilizó el
gobierno de Sudán como fuerza de
contrainsurgencia contra las etnias
africanas ante los escasos avances del
ejército basir armó a pastores árabes de
ganado nómada y los soltó sobre los
granjeros africanos negros la limpieza
étnica fue brutal con 300.000 muertos y
hasta 2,7 millones de personas
expulsadas de sus hogares
La dictadura militar de Sudán ya
acumulada por entonces un historial que
habla por sí solo había sido uno de los
cuatro países del mundo que apoyaron a
Sadam hussein cuando Irak invadió kubai
pero también habían acogido durante unos
años previos el 11s al mismísimo Osama
Bin Laden que organizó en Sudán campos
de entrenamiento de al qaeda vamos que
eran todos unos angelitos con este
historial no os extrañará que el
gobierno de Sudán encargar a los
yanyagüid el trabajo sudar y así es como
Omar albasir se convirtió en el blanco
de todas las críticas internacionales
hasta el punto de llegar a esta
situación en el año 2010 la Corte Penal
Internacional emite orden de arresto por
genocidio contra bashir y así es como
bashir se convirtió en el primer jefe de
estado en ejercicio con una orden de
arresto por la Corte Penal Internacional
y diréis sirvió para algo pues La
respuesta es albasir siguió gobernando
Sudán igualmente y ahora yo os pregunto
si vosotros fuerais el máximo manda más
de Sudán cuál creéis que sería la única
forma de perder el poder al margen de
que te dé un sopondio repentino Exacto
un golpe de estado
albacil tenía muchísimo miedo de un
golpe de estado Así que para protegerse
de su propio crédito regularizó
oficialmente los yagüid convirtiéndolos
en las rapid Support forces es decir las
fuerzas de apoyo rápido es decir dicho
de otra forma su Guardia pretoriana al
frente colocó a su mano derecha en
darfur Mohamed agalo un señor de la
guerra que se ha de llamar emetti el
problema El problema queda resumido en
este viejo proverbio sudanés a nadie le
gusta comer Migajas de un banquete a
todo el mundo le gusta sentarse a la
mesa aislada internacionalmente la
economía sudanesa se deterioraba cada
vez más y la escasez era cada vez mayor
las protestas populares se sucedían y en
abril de 2019 lograron su objetivo sin
embargo mis queridos amigos de
visualpolitik para derrocar al basir fue
necesario sí lo habéis adivinado un
golpe de estado el ejército le dio el
último empujón a albasir cuando vio que
su dictadura estaba tocada de muerte y
qué pasó con la guardia pertoriana
creada para evitar golpes de estado Pues
que su líder geometti apoyó El golpe ya
os lo dije a todo el mundo le gusta
sentarse en la mesa del banquete y al
prescindible sin embargo perder su
posición privilegiada en Sudán era algo
que ni el ejército ni hemetti estaban
dispuestos a permitir y como decimos en
visualpolitik dicho y hecho máximo
general de Sudán toma juramento como
líder del nuevo órgano de gobierno el
general burham se convirtió en el jefe
de estado de Sudán al presidir el nuevo
consejo soberano Y diréis quién estaba
al lado de la mesa del banquete Exacto
el señor de la guerra geometti en este
caso el general burham aprendió la
lección no puedes dejar por ahí suelto
al tipo que lidera los yang yawick
pensad que hablamos de una Fuerza Armada
de 100.000 soldados Así que la mejor
forma de garantizar la lealtad es
sentándole en la mesa del banquete ahora
bien todo esto no le hizo ni pizca de
gracia a los udaneses la gente no se
había levantado contra bashir para que
todo siguiera igual así que los
militares hicieron un pacto con los
líderes civiles compartirían el poder
hasta celebrar elecciones en el año 2022
con estos ingredientes y el historial de
Sudán que podía salir mal en la
transición a la democracia Pues todo
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
el estado profundo versus el pregot sin
africano
el acuerdo de 2019 para compartir el
poder entre civiles y militares era muy
frágil Y diréis por qué Pues básicamente
porque habrá países en el mundo que son
mucho más ricos que este prácticamente
cualquiera pero en pocos te puedes
enriquecer desde el poder Al mismo nivel
que en Sudán para que os hagáis una idea
al antiguo dictador al basir le
Encontraron la friolera de 130 millones
de dólares en efectivo en su casa Sí sí
habéis oído bien en efectivo billetes
dinero con tanta y sonante controlaba la
economía sudanesa a través del ejército
y por supuesto el resto de generales
tampoco tienen sus bolsillos vacíos por
eso cuando el nuevo gobierno civil
aspiró a fijar un nivel de transparencia
y rendición de cuentas digno de la
futura democracia que pretendían
instaurar en Sudán el general burham
sabía perfectamente lo que tenía que
hacer y no no estuvo solo Sudán gmetti
emerge de las sombras Para apoyar El
golpe de estado de buján los donantes
occidentales y los bancos multilaterales
habían prometido miles de millones de
dólares para apoyar esta transición
democrática pero el golpe de estado del
General y geometti en octubre de 2021
impidió que gran parte de esta ayuda
llegara a Sudán Y diréis por qué
[Música]
pues por ejemplo Estados Unidos el Banco
Mundial y el fondo monetario
internacional detuvieron el flujo de al
menos 1400 millones de dólares en ayuda
y alivio a la deuda sudanesa de hecho la
junta militar tuvo que recortar los
subsidios al trigo y al combustible por
esta pérdida de ingresos o de ayudas la
situación en Sudán se volvió
insostenible y los militares se vieron
forzados a negociar con los civiles de
nuevo para avanzar en la transición
democrática y el pasado diciembre
llegaron a un acuerdo Sudán establecerá
un nuevo gobierno de transición liderado
por civiles el 11 de abril el problema
con estos acuerdos Pues es que los
militares tienen mucho que esconder y es
que veréis el general burham quiere
proteger lo que los demócratas sudaneses
llaman el estado profundo hablamos de
todo una red de corporaciones que va
desde bancos y empresas de
telecomunicaciones propiedad de
islamistas y oficiales de inteligencia
hasta empresas propiedad del propio
ejército que dominan sectores económicos
como la fabricación de armas la
construcción la agricultura y el
transporte y algo similar podríamos
decir de emetti convertido en los
últimos años en el africano
es mucho más que un simple señor de la
guerra El dictador vasir dejó que los
yang yawick se hicieran con el control
de las minas ilícitas de oro del país
especialmente en la región de darfur lo
que convirtió ametti en uno de los
hombres más ricos del país Asimismo ha
ganado aún más dinero y aliados
utilizando sus fuerzas de apoyo Rápido
como mercenarios al servicio de emiratos
árabes Unidos para luchar en yemen
contra los Rebeldes suties y en Libia al
lado del General jalifa haftar
el nuevo acuerdo de transición colocó
contra las cuerdas a los dos hombres más
poderosos de Sudán los términos eran muy
claros Sudán tendría un único ejército
bajo el mando del gobierno civil y las
fuerzas de apoyo rápido tendrían que
integrarse en el mismo y como os podéis
imaginar esto amenazaba claramente la
posición privilegiada de ambos primero
la del General burham porque el acuerdo
fijaba elecciones democráticas para el
año 2024 pero también la de geometti
puesto que en dos años debería integrar
su milicia en el ejército algo que el
prision africano pretendía retrasar una
década Por tanto la única salida para
ambos fue el combate armado para ver
quién de los dos prevalece para decidir
el futuro de Sudán y hay la capital del
país está llevando la peor parte las
calles de jartum están devastadas por
conflicto militar el problema de este
conflicto es que es una lucha
equilibrada y diréis pero como puede que
eso sea un problema pues es que si es
muy equilibrada es muy difícil que
alguien se imponga el ejército de Sudán
no vale para mucho pero cuenta con la
Aviación
[Música]
y las fuerzas de apoyo rápido están
mejor armadas y tienen mayor destreza en
combate gracias a su experiencia como
mercenarios sus soldados no han tenido
ningún escrúpulo en tomar viviendas
escuelas e incluso hospitales para
hacerse fuertes en jartum y llevar la
lucha calle a calle ahora bien el
ejército que es el que tiene la fuerza
aérea a bombardeado intensamente la
capital y por si esto fuera poco la
lucha se ha extendido por el resto de
Sudán resucitando viejos Fantasmas del
pasado que amenazan con desembocar en
otro conflicto étnico Mirad los
trabajadores humanitarios son testigos
de cientos de cadáveres asesinados
incluidos niños abandonados en las
calles los yanyagüid cabalgan de nuevo y
el riesgo de nuevos genocidios cobra
fuerza a medida que el conflicto se
prolonga en methty se erige como la
fuerza Rebelde que se ha levantado
contra el gobierno legítimo de Sudán
Pero esto último es también cuestionable
dado el historial golpista del General
burjhan que no es precisamente el mejor
amigo de los demócratas udaneses el
apoyo de las potencias extranjeras
podría ser el que decante la balanza
hacia un lado o hacia otro Y hay muchos
intereses en juego y diréis pero de qué
intereses estamos hablando Pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
el tesoro del mar rojo
las principales potencias en el mar rojo
son Arabia Saudita y Egipto por eso les
interesa que se mantenga el statu quo en
la zona y Eso incluye a Sudán sobre todo
después de la caída de la dictadura de
albasir que se había acercado mucho a
sus rivales Turquía y Qatar Arabia
Saudita y Egipto Se sentían cómodos con
la junta militar de burján y hemetti de
hecho su principal objetivo en Sudán era
evitar una Revolución democrática en el
mundo árabe y por eso apoyaron el Sudán
árabe Saudita Se comprometió a invertir
3.000 millones de dólares pero esperad
un momento porque emiratos árabes Unidos
dobló La Apuesta y diréis Pero por qué
tanto interés la respuesta está en el
mar rojo atentos emiratos árabes Unidos
construirá un puerto en Sudán como parte
de un paquete de inversión de 6.000
millones de dólares a pesar de ser
tradicionalmente aliados como podéis
imaginar este puesto de miratí no le
interesa ni Arabia Saudita ni a Egipto
además el favorito de riad es el general
burham que también es el preferido para
el general al Sisi por los estrechos
lazos que mantienen el ejército de Sudán
y el ejército de Egipto sin embargo mis
queridos amigos de visualpolitik ya os
he contado que el hombre de emiratos
árabes Unidos en Sudán es emetti así que
todos estos intereses cruzados enlazan
con la estrategia creciente de abu dhabi
de desplegar todo su potencial económico
para rivalizar con Arabia Saudita como
referente del mundo árabe
mientras el príncipe pinza el man caían
desgracia en occidente tras el asesinato
de kasogi emiratos árabes Unidos ha
tratado de mostrarse como el rostro
amable de la región al final han
mostrado intereses diferentes en yemen y
en Washington donde abu dhabi ha tratado
de reemplazar a ría como el Aliado
militar favorito de Estados Unidos en el
Golfo
[Música]
mohamedman no ha rehuido la rivalidad y
ahora trata de recuperar terreno podemos
verlo incluso a nivel deportivo que los
emiratos compran el Manchester City Pues
los saudíes compran el newcastle que hay
Fórmula 1 en abu dhabi Pues también en
Arabia Saudita y así con todo por lo
tanto volviendo a la guerra de Sudán
ahora mismo la prioridad de las
potencias regionales no es tanto la paz
como que se imponga el bando que apoya
más aún si en la ecuación añadimos al
grupo Wagner el oro que consigue en
Sudán está llegando a Rusia de
contrabando a través de los emiratos la
Casa Blanca ha tardado un poco pero por
fin movió ficha en este caso contra abu
dhabi Mirad dos empresas de armamento
vinculadas al ejército sudanés han sido
sancionadas por Estados Unidos Mientras
tanto al United un Trader de oro
controlado por gemethi y su hermano y
Trade diff con sede en los emiratos
árabes Unidos también han sido
sancionados los vínculos del grupo
Wagner con geometti se remontan a 2017
en principio Wagner habría dado armas y
formación militar a las fuerzas de apoyo
rápido a cambio de acceso a la hora de
Sudán si Este vídeo lo hubiésemos hecho
hace meses ahora os estaríamos hablando
de como Rusia extiende su influencia por
África pero como os podréis imaginar
después del motín de pregosín el
escenario ha cambiado o quizás no tanto
el kremlin quiere mantener las alianzas
logradas por Wagner lo han dejado bien
claro en la Cumbre con países africanos
que se acaba de celebrar en San
Petersburgo pero necesitan
principalmente por razones económicas y
para eso necesitan
la economía de Rusia está siendo
apuntalada por las operaciones de
contrabando de oro de Wagner Group según
un informe del gobierno del Reino Unido
el oro de Sudán es demasiado Interesante
como para que el kremlin y Wagner dejen
caer también tiene un buen apoyo con
Arabia Saudita que en el año 2022 fue el
quinto país del mundo en gasto militar
tan solo por detrás de Estados Unidos
china Rusia e India así que todo indica
que la guerra de Sudán se va a prolongar
en el tiempo estaremos atentos ya que
estos conflictos suelen desatar una
evidencia enorme y mientras tanto ahora
la pregunta es para vosotros Cómo creéis
que evolucionará la situación en Sudán
se implicará directamente alguna de las
potencias extranjeras podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios y
como siempre no olvidéis Que aquí en
visualpolitik sacamos vídeos nuevos
Todas las semanas así que suscribíos a
este canal y dadle a la campanita para
no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un saludo y hasta pronto
[Música]